[Music]
the MIT Museum is mi t--'s window on the
world and it's also the world's window
on MIT our job in the museum is to make
research and innovation as available and
accessible to ordinary folks as we
possibly can
we're trying to test something that
authorized Albert Einstein he called
spooky actions of the distance we're
testing to the world of the very small
world of atoms and parts of atoms okay
something called quantum entanglement
we're always interested in the museum in
current research at MIT this particular
piece of research intrigued me because
it deals with some of the most basic
ideas in physics which are in turn some
of the most basic ideas we have about
the way the universe works we were very
very lucky to get support for the
experiment a series of experiments from
the US National Science Foundation the
NSF always puts a high premium on what
they call public outreach or public
engagement there are a lot of questions
being asked in the United States today
about what's the point of science and
particularly what's the point of basic
research research asking really
fundamental questions and this is a very
good example of that so this is research
which is really probing some of the most
basic features of the world we live in
right from the beginning my colleagues
and I started to brainstorm what we
might be able to do with this topic
within our museum the project we've
conceived is very if you like multimedia
we have some exhibition components we've
got some displays being built in the
museum we also have programs we have
some seminars and some educational
programs but alongside that maybe some
drama might also help here we have a
unique and created just for this project
one-act play that was developed by the
central square theater as part of the
catalyst collaborative at MIT I had
never even I heard
quantum entanglement before and it was
just mind-boggling and of course the
idea like now you're going to write a 20
minute play about this thing that's
really hard to visualize we can't really
draw a picture of it that was a really
big challenge and I like challenges I
like challenges a lot the play will run
in the museum on many occasions so
museum visitors can come and experience
it and before or after of course explore
the exhibit with the student-made
component so this exhibition is a pretty
concise installation of the concept
where we have MIT students who are
physicists and mathematicians coming in
to actually think about the subject
matter and how to represent it visually
here in the museum we love to work with
MIT students undergraduates and grad
students we think that they get a lot
out of learning how to communicate about
science and we get a lot from their
energy their enthusiasm and their smarts
really our project is called spooky
action and it is a way for people to
experience quantum entanglement
specifically any process whereby two
particles can actually influence each
other's behaviors despite being
physically separated so we try to
visualize that effect by using a strobe
light to highlight certain positions of
the rotating ball and so that the ball
is rotating at a constant rate it's
always continuously moving but the
strobe effect makes it look like it's
frozen in space there are multiple ways
that museum visitors can explore this
concept through the performance through
the exhibit and through the very many
public programs that we're running in
conjunction with the entire topic itself
I think we you know enjoy the challenge
of coming up with new ways of connecting
with audiences we try to create an
engaging setting maybe a non-traditional
setting where folks might feel welcome
if we can excite even a couple of adults
or children to want to take that deeper
dive if that really was the overarching
goal here that gave us the freedom to
try these other
LEDs and mediums and how we communicated
this topic the MIT Museum wants to be an
experimenter it wants to find new ways
of taking science to new audiences and I
think this is going to take a step
further forward to really say let's
wrestle with these these hard contracts
do not shy away from them
what can we do this to try to help
people get there get their hands around
this kind of complicated thing I think
you wrap all those together you have a
really a really amazing experience for
an audience please wow this is wondrous
and if we can inspire sense of wonder I
think that's really exciting
[Music]